I'm going to make a slightly different video from Buch org Kyoetsu.The
town I live in now is located on the east coast of the old city of Beppu, a quiet place full of nature
.  If you don't live in a rural town, you can't imagine it,
so
I'll tell you that there's only one Starbucks.
Because Beppu has a very unique character
, viewers from South Korea and China seemed to nod in agreement.Onsen
Depp is the world's largest hot spring.It
is sandwiched between mountains and the sea, accounting for one-tenth of the total number of hot springs in Japan.
However, Beppu always attracts tourists with a large amount of mysterious steam
coming out of the ground.It is a town where people who have a strangely high sense of local pride want to come.
I didn't know
Seattle Sorry, I'm talking about Beppu this time.
I would like people watching this video to donate to Beppu City
Woman more
Every year, Chouta releases a more fuel-efficient Prius, but no one wants to build a hot spring amusement park on top of a mountain.
Posted a video of Yamagami Onsen amusement park on youtube
Declared that if the number of views of this video reaches 1 million, the
amusement park will be
realized Needless to say, the video, which was a topical announcement, has reached 1 million in 4 days and now  The number has
grown to nearly 3 million,
and the mayor immediately began building the infrastructure to realize the amusement park.
It's been a hot topic lately that it
's like a big-breasted YouTuber who's doing the right thing.
It's through crowdfunding without using
Anyone who lives in Japan, regardless of nationality,
should know how unusual this behavior is.
It takes tremendous courage.
The
point is that fake news and insults fly like greetings.I
really like the mayor of Nagano, who is trying to do something like this boldly,
and I want to actively support him.That's why I made this video.
We have created a funding page and have
already collected quite a lot of donations, but
there are two problems with the campaign: the page is only in Japanese, and the
minimum donation is 3,000 yen.  The reason why there is no specification for the people in the department even
if they want to support.I want to do what I can to solve this problem.
se Biological face
I'm in Enderwatch 8 cards Queen Burford separate rose balloon
click to support Projector 2g accessor
in to me as respond
sendmail again for amaba somap gobaud
Mainekron s 4 stay game name
5 bed page re Shuin  pu uruu johnny year formation
new pass 4
this to ano let up to b turtle pagen tour
ren this page 22 species a japanese back 2 d with wing
wedding wig only be sekihira chogyua
u avoid 1 bd me  Pou
dou dou actor oda Car formation page
mu Dam da page
Yugyufai no glue and cation 3 Fence waiter page End a
gradation 10 p calm pay to
how to live Ding
Yes, I think you all now know how to use the Japanese page, but I
think the minimum donation of 3,000 yen is still too high for a lot of people.
cow in
this video  I explained the situation and asked them to add a lower donation
amount.I think that if it goes well, people who can't speak Japanese and people who are living with cup ramen
will be able to contribute.Thank you everyone.
As I said at the beginning, I think it's a pretty interesting idea, so I'd like to support
it with all my might.